Okay.
Yeah.
The thing is we have multiple goals,
right?
So on the question of stability,
democracy is in really good shape.
Uh,
in fact,
I would say that in the 2000 election
cycle,
um,
one of the things that really got
celebrated when George Bush and Al Gore
were running for president,
they get this quirky result.
Everyone's fighting it out over the
hanging chads in Florida.
Of all the things that I worry about,
who won the election for,
you know,
a couple of months and,
and that we came out of that process and
we ended up with a precedent.
There was no military coup,
there was no huge set of demonstrations.
And for many people,
this constituted a success,
a win for democracy,
that we are a country that is so stable,
so rule of law,
so willing to wait for the process to
work.
Then in fact,
we can have stable transitions of
leadership even when things are looking
kind of rough.
So on the one hand,
one might say,
well,
democracy is great.
We're,
we're quite stable.
But I think that the story of the 2000
elections could be told another way as
well.
There was no military coup.
There was no outright uprising in the
streets.
Right.
In other words,
all the things that that one might have
celebrated as being about stability,
one might also suggest,
uh,
reflects a lack of robustness,
a lack of engagement,
um,
a willingness to defer to authority and
to rule of law,
even if in fact it gives us outcomes
that have terrible consequences for
decades to come.
So I think,
I think it does depend on sort of how
one might measure or judge the value or
quality of democracy.
On the one hand,
a great deal of stability,
on the other hand,
a great deal of violence on the part of
ordinary people,
sort of an inability to really penetrate
the elites and to really demonstrate and
discuss what the central issues facing
sort of ordinary Americans are.